this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant org a
problem solving website that helps you
think like an engineer guns are a
technology whose roots can be traced all
the way back to 12th century China and
although the technology has advanced
beyond recognition with the guns growing
in size and power their ammunition has
evolved from spherical to the more
familiar bullet shape to make them more
efficient at supersonic speeds the
barrels have been bored with twists who
impaired a spin on the round to make it
more accurate and the method of their
transportation has revolutionized how
they're used but there has been one
constant for this technology through the
centuries today we're going to learn how
this technology looks set to be
revolutionized by its largest iteration
to date with the invention of the rail
gun rail guns are guns that use
electromagnetic force to propel a
projectile instead of an explosive using
explosives to power artillery has some
drawbacks perhaps the most glaring one
being that naval ships have to carry
huge caches of explosives on board to
power their guns and this has backfired
several times throughout history
particularly during world war ii went on
multiple occasions Japanese attacks
detonated huge stores of ammunitions
within ships with the most horrifying
case being the kamikaze attack on the
USS john burke where the resulting
explosion dwarfed the gigantic ships in
his convoy obviously avoiding future
cases of this would be ideal but this
isn't the only advantage current railgun
designs are doubling the muzzle velocity
of all naval artillery with hypersonic
speeds up to Mach 6 most naval artillery
max out at Mach 3 this would extend the
range and reduce the time to impact by
nearly double - it wasn't for the
elevated air resistance of these feats
and this technology has been a focus of
the US military for decades and for good
reason
so let's see how it works and what needs
to improve before we see it introduced
to service rail guns use
electromagnetism to propel a conductive
armature housing the projectile
downrange the physics is quite simple
however the math is not two parallel
rods are connected to a power source and
these two rods can be considered the
weapons barrel connecting these two rods
and completing the circuit is the
armature as the current passes through
the rails it generates a magnetic field
the same happens as a passes through the
armature the interaction of these
perpendicular currents
through the magnetic field produces
something called the Lorentz force this
force acts both perpendicular to the
flow of the current and the magnetic
field in the case of the railgun this
force is what pushes the projectile
through the barrel and downrange the
beauty of the Lorentz force is that it's
consistent meaning the longer the barrel
the higher the muzzle velocity but the
power required to simply overcome the
static friction within the barrel of a
miniature railgun can require
significant amounts of energy most
individuals don't easily have access to
this is when things start to get
extremely interesting or extremely
challenging because both solving for the
Lorentz force and generating sufficient
Lorentz force are both huge engineering
challenges that have only been made
possible and sustainable in the last 20
years
the Lorentz force in the case of a
railgun is simply the current multiplied
by the armature with the magnetic field
in Tesla's and sine theta where theta is
the angle of the current which in this
case is 90 degrees the magnetic field B
is a property of the railguns design
such as materials rail separation and
diameter and overall design geometry
with some assumptions the equations
clean up a bit
but for actual railgun design these
assumptions can't be made while this
technology has huge potential there are
some problems that need to be overcome
to make this a serious weapon system
first and foremost the same force that
is applied to the armature also acts on
the parallel rails quite literally every
time the weapon system is fired the gun
is actively trying to tear itself apart
on top of all this the heat generated
during each shot is so immense it is
melting the rails this can be seen
during test fire drills with prototype
railgun systems that discharge you see
behind the projectile is not the result
of explosive propulsion what a result of
the resistive electric heating created
by the huge current running through the
rails and the frictional force between
the armature and the rail causing the
rails to melt and shed material during
each shot causing more damage to the
rail these are unavoidable side effects
which are currently limiting the railgun
to just a few shots before the damage
breaks the gun entirely next and
possibly the most obvious limitation to
the railgun design as a whole is power
for this weapon to ever be introduced to
service it would have to be paired with
a power source capable of providing the
25 megawatts needed to fire
even if previous generation ships had
this capability they would not have had
enough power in reserve after satisfying
the needs to the onboard systems and
propulsion but America's new futuristic
zumwalt-class destroyer is an
all-electric composite ship that was
slated to test this new weapon with a
generator capable of creating 78
megawatts it would still have 58
megawatts of capacity available after
providing for the rest of the ships
essential power requirements
difficulties in railgun development and
fiscal pull backs and some wall
construction have delayed their
introduction but they can unlikely will
be retrofitted in the coming years once
the current durability problems have
been solved and while this technology is
currently being funded by the military
and as far-reaching potential for other
industries we spoke recently of the
challenges of intercepting ICBMs with
traditional missiles rail guns could
allow multiple interceptors to be
quickly fired at a fraction of the cost
and increased the chances of success
they have even been suggested as a means
of protecting the earth from asteroids
with huge versions in orbit to destroy
or change the direction of incoming
asteroids launching a satellite like
this could also be made drastically
cheaper too if we can deliver the
materials to orbit with nothing more
than the force and magnetic field impact
on a moving electric charge if you'd
like to learn more about electricity and
magnetism and how they affect the world
around us or any number of other
scientific and mathematical principles
the best way to learn and understand
principles like this is by applying them
yourself and that's exactly what
brilliant org allows you to do one of my
goals with this channel is to inspire my
viewers to follow the path of past
engineers to make this world a better
place but to do that you have to learn
how to apply these principles yourself
brilliant is a problem-solving site that
helps you think like an engineer by
guiding you through problems that are
broken into digestible sections that
bring you from knowing nothing to having
a deep understanding of the topic what I
love is that when you answer something
incorrectly it even tells you exactly
why so you can correct your
misconceptions to support real
engineering and learn more about
brilliant go to brilliant org ford slash
real engineering and sign up for free
and the first 200 people that go to that
link will get 20% off their annual
premium subscription brilliant is a
perfect fit for my channel so please
check them out as usual thank you to all
my patreon supporters for helping this
channel exist
self and Sam from Wendover productions
just released the latest episode of her
podcast show makers with special guests
Christian Tierney who is an incredible
photographer and videographer who
recently worked with Conor McGregor for
his last fight with Floyd Mayweather the
link for that should be on screen now